well we have a question about influences
and they are wondering who are the
important influences on each of you and
then they asked George they say they
have knowledge that you have listed both
Lovecraft and Faulkner among your
influences and how do you square the
tension between their purple and spare
prose which one is spare farmer and
Lovecraft yeah is there there's no
spareness those influence on me
you know Wow why I read his books I
haven't read all of his work by any
means but well I read some of it but the
greatest influence that Faulkner has had
on me is his a Nobel Prize acceptance
speech which if you haven't read it you
can find it online and it's a it's a
very moving speech about the kind of
writing he was doing and what he thinks
fiction should be about them in
particular he said the only thing worth
writing about is the human heart in
conflict with itself and I've taken that
particular phrase as kind of a mantra
for my work and that's where I think all
of this stuff about genre it is
unimportant because if it is a important
work we are all writing about the human
heart in conflict with itself whether
it's not a spaceship or inside a
medieval castle in some fantasy land or
whether it's in suburban Chicago and a
mainstream novel doesn't matter we're
telling stories about the human heart in
conflict with itself and I think Hawkins
nailed it there and that's Lovecraft
I think was the greatest horror writer
who ever lived he's certainly one of the
big three he's right up there with
Stephen King and Edgar Allan Poe there
are many other good horror writers but
nobody approaches those three and he
just scared the bejesus out of me when I
encountered his work at the age of 13 or
so and I still do occasionally when I
when I reach for a scary effect in a
book or a story I reach for Lovecraftian
effects he's he's a writer I've
sometimes tried to echo or write like I
don't think I can I'm not you know
I don't have the deep level of insanity
I think that drove some of some of his
best work but yes he did have a huge
influence on me
along with science fiction and fantasy
writers I mean Toki and Rory Howard on
the fantasy side Fritz library to a
certain extent on the science fiction
side Robert a Heinlein Andre Norton who
is another writer that I read you know
when I was quite young I think the
biggest influences you are other people
you read when you're young I mean I'm 68
years old now I I read many books that
are good and I admire them but they're
not gonna influence me I'm not gonna
find a new writer oh my god this guy
I've got a I've got to try to do what
he's doing here no they influences a
role in your formative years when you're
when you're still vulnerable to
influences yeah let's see I think we've
got to for George I'm going to ask them
both to you together who would you want
to see on the Iron Throne dead or alive
you can think about that one then who's
deaf do you regret the must
[Applause]
who would I like to see on the Iron
Throne well I'm not going to reveal that
you're gonna have to keep reading the
books of my dad to find out there that's
a little little too much you guys argue
about that whose death do I regret the
most John F Kennedy and Bobby Kennedy
okay I have one final question for both
of you so what are you most excited
about in the field of science and
fiction and fantasy today what what
excites you about where the fields going
do you have particular writers you think
everybody should be reading there's a
lot of writers coming in science fiction
has conquered the world from from this
little ghetto genre that you know you
weren't supposed to associate with we've
taken over the world we've taken over
television we've taken over movies most
of the highest-grossing movies or
old-time are science fiction fantasy
movies comic book movies and all that
and as a result of that of course more
and more people are entering the field
and there are some extraordinary new
talents that that are coming up and
that's all that's all very exciting to
me admittedly there's so much of it that
I often feel like I can't keep up just
because there are so many new people
entering you know there was a time once
upon a time when certain science fiction
fans like first a Ackerman were able to
read everything every science fiction
book published in the year oh all the
magazines all the novels he read them
all but even by the 70s when I broke in
you couldn't do that any longer but then
there was another time like 20 years was
yeah there was a lot of books being
published a lot of stories you couldn't
read them all but some of them you know
were more important than others and you
could kind of keep up with the important
parts of the field you can't do that
anymore either the field has diversified
so much in terms of genres and subgenres
I mean we have we have epic fantasy and
high fantasy and dark fantasy and urban
fantasy and you know we go on with that
though you know science fiction we have
the cyberpunk movement and you know the
the well the New Wave is pretty well
gone but it left its residues on the
shore we have the new space opera the
new weird all of these famous and you
can just read in one of these subgenres
and still
have more books and more writers and
more stories to read than you ever had
before one of the things that is
exciting to me is the fact that not only
is the field becoming more diverse in
terms of subject matters and subgenres
but it's becoming more diverse sexually
and ethnically and nationally where
we're seeing more and more I mean
there's I don't want to say that they've
never been there have always been women
writing science fiction and some great
ones Andre Norton one of the formative
writers of my own youth was actually
Alice Mary Norton and you had Leigh
Brackett and steal more two incredible
writers of the of the Golden Age and
there was a huge influence of women in
the 70s but today there's it's many more
it's exponentially larger and we're
seeing more and more writers from other
countries with six in Lu won the Hugo
Award the first translated novel he's a
Chinese writer in China three-body
problem one of the you go award first
time a translated novel has ever won and
in the same year a Dutch writer for a
translated novel that I believe also won
so we had two translations science
fiction has conquered not only United
States but the entire world I mean books
are being published in all these
countries and they're largely American
and just lesser extent British books but
now for the first time we're getting a
reciprocation on that the you know we're
getting their visions as well as them
getting our visions so I think all that
is it's tremendously exciting well I
share these sentiments we come from a
time when science fiction was looked
down on and so I personally have a chip
on my shoulder that will never go away
and I'd like to punch people who don't
like science fiction and yet now we are
all living in a science fiction novel
that we are co-writing together it's
called reality so the predictions came
right and because of the work of people
like George it's it's really essential
to the culture
people talk right in terms of Game of
Thrones because everybody's read it or
seen it and can understand each other's
references and that is a very
heartwarming experience and then in
terms of new writers I think one of the
things that happens is it's harder to
look down the generations to new work
than it is to look to the generation
right before you which is so incredibly
vivid to the mind as a reader but I will
say that I see when I test out the
waters because I'm always trying to not
know what's going on so that I can do my
own thing without fear of learning
anything from anybody else I would say
that when I talk about younger writers
I'm see great work by Jonathan Lethem or
Cory Doctorow or Paolo Bacigalupi also
Kelly link or Nora Jamison or Nettie
Okafor and almost kind of these people
are probably nearly 50 years old so my
sense it doesn't vary from the fact
there are newer new people there are but
I don't know people those are in the
mist to me and that I have not explored
the the latest work being done I'm
confident it's out there and that it's
great and it's you know that's not
really my job as a as a reader I'm I'm
still reading Daniel Defoe with immense
pleasures you know I'm a little off the
cutting edge but I love it all I'm
really excited about all the amazing
work that's come out of Clarion in the
last few years a little long and Sam
Miller
Carmen Machado so many people just what
do you see an amazing work so rush out
and read work by all those people if you
yes haven't heard of them